>>commentator: Good afternoon everyone. We're
proud to have Steve Lehto, author of Mis-Michigan's
Columbus: The Life of Douglass Houghton here
in our Ann Arbor Google office today.
It was named one of Michigan's most notable
books of 2010. Steve brings us this captivating
story of Douglass Houghton. As Michiganers
we know that the name Houghton is incredibly
well known and graces the name of not only
a city, a county, a lake, waterfalls, schools,
and even a Google conference room.
This story is about Michigan's first geologist
turned explorer, Houghton's Journey. He discovered
more than any man before him, became the Mayor
of Detroit, and taught at the University of
Michigan all before the age of 36.
In addition to being a talented author, Steve
is also an attorney and professor here in
Southeast Michigan. He spends a lot of his
time speaking about these topics and other
Michigan history whenever he gets the opportunity.
So without any further ado, please help us
in welcoming our guest, Steve Lehto.
[applause]
>>Steve Lehto: Thank you.
I'll do my best without the audio-visual presentation.
Douglass Houghton is the subject of the book,
Michigan's Columbus, and it's interesting
because I did not coin the phrase "Michigan's
Columbus." That was actually a phrase attributed
to, given to him by several other people previously
and it's-it's one of those things people ask
me they say, "Steve why would him Michigan's
Columbus?" I say, "Well, don't worry Columbus
didn't actually discover America and Houghton
didn't discover Michigan," but he was an explorer
and that's the whole point is that the most,
foremost explorer in Michigan history is Douglass
Houghton.
So Douglass Houghton born in New York in the
early 1800's and in a town called Fredonia,
New York, believe it or not near Troy, and
he grew up in the area and went to school
and went to Rensselaer Polytechnic where he
got a degree in geology.
And while he was attending their school he
also was working on getting his medical degree.
This is a time back then when you wouldn't
go to medical school to become a doctor you'd
actually apprentice with someone, and after
you learned enough medicine you'd then go
stand before the local medical board and if
they thought you were good for doctoring you'd
became a doctor.
And so as he was finishing up his bi-geology
degree and his medical degree the people of
Detroit decided that they needed someone to
come into town and help them out.
And in the 1830's the population of the City
of Detroit was two thousand. At one point
in time the population was 2222, two thousand
two hundred and twenty two people. And at
that point in time it was simply just like
the entryway to the Northwest Territory. If
you look on a map you'll see that the Lake
Ontario, Lake Erie and then the Michigan Territory
would spread far of the west from that.
And the Michigan Territory at that time, the
1830's, actually included what is now Michigan,
Wisconsin, Minnesota, and half of North and
South Dakota. So for instance, the headwaters
of the Mississippi River were in the Michigan
Territory in 1831.
So the fathers of Detroit actually sent an
emissary back east to Rensselaer with the
mission to find somebody who could come to
Detroit and deliver lectures on wholesome
topics. They actually thought that if they
didn't have something like this going on there'd
be too much temptation among the local people
to do things like drink and gamble and womanize,
unless of course you're a woman and whatever
the equivalent to that is.
[laughter]
And so they asked Houghton if he would come
back to Detroit and deliver lectures. And
so interestingly enough, he agreed to do it.
He was a young man probably 20, 21 years old
when he got the offer and he agreed to come
to Detroit and the promise of employment was
simply, "You can give lectures and people
will attend the lectures and you can charge
admission and that admission will be your
salary."
So Houghton moves to Detroit, he delivers
the lectures, and it turns out they were a
raging success. Houghton is delivering lectures
on things like rocks and trees --
[laughter]
and plants and farming, all extremely important
things though on the frontier.
And at that point in time Detroit is also
the capital of the Michigan Territory. So
although there's only two or three thousand
people there, a lot of them are the important
people in the Territory. People like Lewis
Cass, Henry Schoolcraft and the names that
you see now on maps in Michigan or on streets
in Michigan or on roads around Google.
[laughter]
Okay, that's where a lot of these names came
from.
So when Houghton was in Detroit giving his
lecture invariably a lot of the famous people
in Detroit, the movers and shakers, came and
saw him speak and so he became very well known.
And Henry Schoolcraft in particular recognized
that here's a young guy, he's a scientists,
he's a doctor, but he's also a very, very
smart guy who can explain stuff to people.
So Henry Schoolcraft approached Houghton and
said, "I'm putting together an expedition
to go find the headwaters of the Mississippi."
They'd never been marked by white men before.
So Schoolcraft got federal funding, Douglass
Houghton and a bunch of other men and they
went up to find the headwaters of the Mississippi[bad
audio] in the Michigan Territory.
Amazingly enough they went there from Detroit
by canoe.
[laughter]
So they got in a canoe and paddled up the
Detroit River, across Lake St. Clair, up Lake
Huron, dragged the canoe over the falls at
St. Mary's Falls, and then canoed across Lake
Superior, and then went down into Minnesota,
and eventually found the headwater of the
Mississippi.
They made that trip twice, once one year and
once the second year. And in the second year
they did it they actually found the headwaters
of the Mississippi and Henry Schoolcraft has
gone down in history as being the first white
man to mark the headwaters of the Mississippi,
which are now in Minnesota.
But while Houghton was on that trip he also
was exploring and making note of the geological
things he saw. And along the way he actually
did see the Ontonagon Boulder and visited
the copper country which is the [Quina] Peninsula
of the Upper Peninsula of Michigan. So he
became very, very aware of that in the 1830's.
So after these trips were over he wrote some
reports about this and in fact one of his
reports was circulated in Washington D.C.
because at that time portions of the Northwest
Territory were not states. Michigan wasn't
even a state yet. And there was a lot of speculation
about whether or not Michigan should become
a state or what they should do and how they
should divide up the area.
So in 1835 Michigan actually had enough people
to apply for statehood. You needed to have
60,000 people living within your borders and
then you draft a constitution and you apply
for statehood.
So Michigan applied for statehood, we hold
a constitutional convention, and we get blocked
by Ohio. And I like to mention for number
one because we're in Ann Arbor obviously and
everyone knows that the old saying, "Oh how
I hate Ohio State." It actually dates back
to the Ohio war that Michigan had with-with
them and the Toledo war.
And there's a borderline between Michigan
and Ohio and if you look on a map it's not
straight. The reason it's not straight is
that when Ohio became a state in 1803 they
unilaterally declared a straight line from
the bottom of Lake Michigan over above Toledo
to Lake Erie.
When the federal government surveyed it they
actually said is should be a straight line
to the bottom of Lake Michigan over to the
bottom of Toledo which would put Toledo in
Michigan. But Mi-Ohio became a state first,
they declared Toledo as part of their state.
If you went to Toledo in the 1820's and asked
people there, "What state do you live in?"
Most of them would have said, "We-we live
in Michigan." But Ohio didn't think that.
So when we applied for statehood, Congress
has gotta pass on any state that wants to
join the Union. And Ohio actually lobbied
actively to block us from getting into the
Union. And we had no votes in Congress because
we're not a state yet. So we go to Congress,
they vote us down. We go to Congress, they
vote us down.
While all this is going on, a friend of Douglass
Houghton's who's the Governor of Michigan,
Stevens T. Mason, they call him "the little,
the boy governor." Stevens Mason was about
this tall and Douglass Houghton was about
this tall --
[laughter]
they called Douglass Houghton a little doctor,
he five foot four, so he's probably about
this tall.
Stevens T. Mason rounded up a militia of Michigan
men, a Michigan Militia, and basically sent
them down to protect the Toledo strip from
Ohio marauders. And it's a fascinating concept,
there's a whole, been books written about
the Toledo war.
We actually sent Michigan Militiamen down
there. They sent up Ohio Militiamen and there
would actually be skirmishes in the Toledo
Strip. And at the time there wasn't much there.
No one ever got shot; no one ever got killed;
and the only injuries we know of was that
someone got stabbed in the back in a bar on
a Friday night, which happens every night
in Toledo.
[laughter]
So we're not sure if that's actually a war
wound or not, but that's the upshot of it.
What wound up happening though was after all
the squabbling got back and forth and it was
getting to the point where it was very embarrassing
that this is happenin', somebody pulled aside
Stevens T. Mason and said, "Look you guys
are never gonna' win this 'cause you, you
don't have the votes in-in Washington to do
it. How 'bout this? We'll give you the western
two-thirds of the Upper Peninsula as part
of your state and you give up the little strip
of Toledo." And so they agreed to do that.
So it took two years of squabbling but we
basically gave up the strip of land that contained
Toledo it's like just a few hundred square
miles and we picked up a couple hundred thousand
acres of land in the Upper Peninsula based
on that.
And so we got the western two-thirds, we actually
got all the way up from Sault Saint Marie
all the way over to what is now the-the line
between us and Wisconsin, Iron River, Iron
Mountain, Iron Wood, the Irons over there.
So we picked up all that land in exchange
for it.
The amazing thing is that back then all the
editorials in the newspapers talked about
how we got ripped off.
[laughter]
Because you think about this, in a time before
transportation, no roads, the only way to
get up there was by canoe and it takes you
a month to get there, very few people in Detroit
would ever see the Upper Peninsula. So to
have given up Toledo which is their backyard
for someplace, it's like giving us something
on the moon or the North Pole.
[laughter]
So we got the Upper Peninsula in exchange
for that.
Now that we're a state, Detroit's the capital,
they hold a legislative meeting, we elect
all kinds of people, and the first thing the
legislature does when their in session is
they appoint Douglass Houghton state geologist.
It's interesting because we still have a state
geologist today but nost, most people have
no idea who he is. I've met the guy, he's
a very nice guy.
[laughter]
But back then it was an extremely important
position. Michigan was a young state. To raise
money they either raised taxes, which they
don't wanna do first day in office, or they
could send somebody out and say, "Find natural
resources that we can exploit."
So they sent Houghton out with the job of
looking for natural resources that could be
exploited especially if he could find any
minerals that could be mined: copper, gold,
silver, and then also salt.
When you're on the frontier in the 1830's
there's no refrigeration, you need salt for
your food otherwise stuff spoils, you can
get all kinds of weird diseases, so salt is
extremely important and we were importing
a lot of salt from the State of New York at
that time. We had a trade deficit with New
York on salt.
So Douglass Houghton goes out in 1837 in the
fall to explore Michigan. Now it's kinda late
in the year, he can only do a short trip,
so him and his men pack up their wagons and
they hike for an entire day out of Detroit
and camp for the night in Royal Oak.
So those of you who are familiar with the
layout of Michigan you know that you can do
that drive today by car in about 10 minutes,
on a bicycle you can do it in an afternoon.
And they camped for the night in Royal Oak.
The next morning they get up, they pack up
all the stuff, they hike for another complete
day and they camp the night in Pontiac.
The third night they're camping so far out
in the wilderness that one of the guys writes
in his journal about how they're hearing wild
animals they don't know what they are, they're
seeing trees they've never seen before, they're
out in a crazy wilderness, and they're still
in Oakland County.
[laughter]
But that's how undeveloped it was at the time.
So these guys travel, they finally make it
up to Tittabawassee River which is up near
Corunna and they get in the canoe and they
paddle out to the Saginaw Bay area, and while
they're out there they actually find the salt
wells that became part of the basis believe
it or not for the Dow Chemical Company.
And if you go to the town of Sanford, Michigan
today there's a historical marker where the
first salt well was sunk by men that Douglass
Houghton said, "Dig a well here."
So the first year, and people from Michigan
know about this, the first year they went
up and around the thumb like this.
The second year he then went up and went around
the entire lower Michigan.
And every time he went he'd bring a bunch
of guys with him and he would be keeping a
journal everywhere he went and his journals
survived. We still have them today.
And also with him on the trips there was always
two or three other guys keeping journals and
a lot of their journals survived as well.
And it's fascinating because some of these
trips there'd be Douglass Houghton and two
or three other guys all keeping daily journals
of everything they did. And you can compare
them side by side and reconstruct these trips
on a daily basis, so it's fascinating.
Because Douglass Houghton is gathering samples
largely rocks and the other guys are doing
the paddling, they'd actually hire guys to
do nothing but paddle. He'd hire, they called
'em voyagers or couriers, and they would do
nothing but paddle for you all day long. You're
like hired mules but in a canoe.
And so they went up and around and he's always
looking for marketable resources. So for instance,
in the Lower Peninsula not far past Saginaw
there's a town called Alabaster, still on
the maps today. If you go there today there's
not much there, but you can see the evidence
where there used to be open pit mines there
and they used to mine gypsum and alabaster.
If you ever read the book Devil in the White
City by Erik Larson about the Chicago World's
Fair in 1893 and the-the serial killer there,
it's a fascinating book. Anyways they called
it The White City because they built these
buildings that were bright, brilliant white
and the-the white in the cement came from
gypsum and alabaster from Alabaster, Michigan
and that was discovered by Houghton and his
men in 1838.
So they also found like this rocks that he
[ ] Drummond Island. They found clay in a
bunch of different places. They found salt
springs over in Grand Rapids and so on.
So he'd do, he'd do a trip around, come back
to Detroit for the winter, write his report,
give his report to the legislature. And he's,
he's a government official so he's getting
paid a salary to do this and then a-a-a-a
budget to do this as well.
So 1837 he does the thumb; 1838 does lower
Michigan; 1839 he goes up and he goes across
the bottom of the Upper Peninsula and then
back around Lake Michigan.
And on that trip, for instance, he actually
encounters a-a-a-a flower growing on the beach
that looks like goldenrod. And Houghton beside
being a geologist and a doctor was also an
amateur biologist and he recognized that the
goldenrod looked funny so he brought some
samples home and he showed them to a friend
of his named Zina Pitcher who is also I think
a professor at U of M and he said, "Yes, that
is a previously unidentified goldenrod." So
it's now called Houghton's goldenrod.
So if you go to the DNR Website for the State
of Michigan under endangered species there's
actually goldenrod that you can only find
it growing in the wet sand between the high
water mark in the sand dunes at the tops of
Lake Michigan and Lake Huron and its endangered.
It only grows in this little, tiny little
strips of grass and most people don't know
what they are but its goldenrod, it looks
a little different than typical goldenrod.
The whole time Houghton's doing his exploring
though he was being pushed the whole time
because people wanted him to go explore the
copper country.
People had known about the copper in the Upper
Peninsula for probably about 300 years at
that point. There are stories in Europe in
the 1600's of there being large deposits of
copper someplace in the new world.
And a lot of people outside of Michigan don't
know this but copper in nature normally does
not occur in its natural form. Usually it's
ore that has to be processed and crushed and
smelted, but if you go to the Upper Peninsula
of Michigan you can sim-simply walk around
on a rock pile and find pieces of pure copper.
They call it native copper.
And native copper's unusual in the world but
it-it-it's largest concentration is in the
Upper Peninsula of Michigan.
People have known about that for years and
in fact when Houghton had gone to the Schoolcraft
expedition they had visited a boulder that's
called the Ontonagon Boulder. The Ontonagon
Boulder was this large piece of copper out
in the woods next to the Ontonagon River.
And every single person that went to the Upper
Peninsula back then who's an explorer would
visit this boulder and it was a rock that
was so big that grown men couldn't move it.
And they'd come back to Detroit where ever
they came from, Montreal, and they'd tell
their friends, "We-we hiked up in the woods
and there's this boulder out there and we
couldn't move it."
And the funny thing is by the time people
stumbled back to civilization after spending
months getting out to this thing, the boulder
got bigger and heavier.
[laughter]
So that by the time the story got told it
was always a 10,000 pound or 20,000 pound
boulder. And in fact in Schoolcraft's book,
he wrote several books, one of his books he
has an illustration showing the boulder and
he shows a canoe of Indians paddling across
the river over towards this thing the size
of a garage --
[laughter]
and in reality the Ontonagon Boulder is about
the size of a microwave oven. It's about this
big. And we know how much it weighs, it weighs
3,700 pounds. But the interesting thing is
that the tales of the Ontonagon Boulder coming
back to Detroit, the stories coming down had
spurred to think, "Oh my gosh there's this
copper laying around up there just to be picked
up off the ground."
So in 1840 Douglass Houghton and his men went
across the shore of Lake Superior on the northern
shore of the Upper Peninsula, got to the copper
country and spent a lot of time exploring
Quina Peninsula. While they were up there
Houghton gathered samples of both the native
ore and the copper ore and, the native copper
and the copper ore, and the ore he brought
back was 47 percent pure. And there was a
copper industry in Cornwall, England based
on ore that's no better than 12 percent copper.
So he said, "This ore shows that they can
mine it up here" and that's great. And he
also noted the fact that there this-this native
copper there in huge quantities as well.
So he wrote that report and they referred
to that as his 1841 report and that's the
one that they often talk about being the one
that sparks the copper industry up there because
he was the first person of any learning to
actually write a report that said, "Yes it's
up here. It can be mined and-and someone can
establish an industry based on this."
People took his report to Boston and got investors
to put up the money to start the companies
that became the Quincy and the Cliff and the
Calumet and Hecla and so on.
So that's Houghton's work as a geologist.
So it's 1841 he's basically done now though.
So Douglass Houghton then on top of everything
else he's done, then approaches the federal
government and he-he's also trained as a surveyor.
Back then surveyors were very common, it's
kinda like lawyers today, everybody knew a
surveyor. They often joked that Mt. Rushmore
is three surveyors and a president,
[laughter]
because three of the four presidents on Mt.
Rushmore were surveyors.
So Douglass Houghton went to the federal government
and got a contract to finish the survey of
the Upper Peninsula of Michigan. And if you
ever go to Sault Saint Marie there's actually
a-a-a-a spot, I have a photograph of it I'd
like to show it to you later.
If you look at a map of Michigan there's Baseline
Road which is the baseline that runs across
the bottom of the State of Michigan, it's
also 8 Mile Road. There's also a line that
runs North-South called the Meridian. And
the Meridian when it goes through Lansing
for instance becomes a road called Meridian
and there's a mall called Meridian Mall on
that road. Every property description in Michigan
is based on its relationship to the intersection
of those two lines. It's like a big grid.
So they would start in Sault Saint Marie and
survey their way across working west from
the Meridian and they knew how far north they
were from the Baseline.
So it's an interesting thing is that if you
go up the Upper Peninsula today and find the
property descriptions, and go find the corners
of those property descriptions many of those
corners were marked by Douglass Houghton and
his men back in 1844 and 1845.
And in fact in the book I've got a photograph
of a Barren Tree. And what that is is when
they got to a corner of an intersection it's
very, very important, like the corner between
two townships, if there was a tree near it
they'd actually take out a big piece of metal
and they'd carve off the bark and take a scribe
and carve numbers into the side of the tree.
So it'd say like, "33 north, 58 west, section
16." And then they'd make a note in their
field book that, "Okay, we marked the corner
of that intersection on the side of this tree."
And so years later people would when they're
redoing the surveys or they're checkin' the
property descriptions would actually find
the tree and say, "Okay, there's the tree
that was marked."
And I've spoken to guys at Michigan Tech in
this, they have a survey department there,
they actually teach surveying as a, as a,
as a vocation, who told me that to this day
they still walk the woods and find barren
trees marked by these guys in the 1840's and
1850's. The trees are still there. Some of
them have fallen over but the photograph that
I have in the book was taken in 1910 I believe
which would have been 55 years after Houghton's
men marked it. The tree was still alive and
kicking then and it was just many, many years
later it may have fallen down. They've gone
back and remarked these things.
The amazing thing is that these guys were
actually working with nothing more but-but-but
basically the transits that you look through
and basically rumors, big chains they would
stretch to measure distances. And even working
that way across the state very, very slowly
they actually on the far end of the state
had a margin of error plus or minus only like
10 feet, which is amazing to think about in
a day long before GPS's and satellites.
If you think about just the difficulty of
shooting a straight line across a swamp or
through woods or across a mountain ridge and
it's interesting because when I was researching
the book I'd known about him doing the geological
work, I didn't even know that he was a-a surveyor
when I first [ ] work on the book.
I actually found a, an article written by
his nephew and his nephew had actually worked
for him one summer doing survey work. And
his nephew had basically gotten a job as a
gopher on the expedition of 1845 and one of
the things he talks about doing is carrying
barometers.
And that answered one of the questions that
I had is how they do elevation changes because
if you think about it, I mean I suppose you
could triangulate elevation changes, but actually
it's easier to for instance when you're at
Copper Harbor where they spent one summer
you have one guy sit down at the lake shore
with a barometer and take barometric readings
at the top and bottom of every hour. And then
if you're out in the woods hiking and you're
surveying you get to the top or bottom of
something you stop there and wait for the
top or bottom of the hour and you get your
barometric pressure reading and then at the
end of the day you go back and you recorrelate
those two. And what's amazing to get is that
all of this stuff turns out to be relatively
accurate especially considering how primitive,
primitive this was at the time.
So the other interesting thing that came out
of Houghton's survey work as he surveyed the
Upper Peninsula is that as they're workin'
their way across he contracted out a lot of
the work and one of the guys he contracted
with was a guy named William Burt. And William
Burt was inventor and he had invented a typewriter
that he had a patent on already and he also
had invented a thing called equatorial sextant
which was a-a basically a solar compass. It's
the kind of thing that you see a pirate using
to measure the stars if you look at the stars,
but this was designed to be used from daylight
to measure the angle of the sun to figure
out north, south, east, and west.
And when he patented it people had actually
said to him, "This is a nonsensical thing.
You don't need this on land because you can
always use a compass." Well when they were
surveying across the Upper Peninsula when
they got to the Negaunee Marquette area compasses
don't work because there's so much iron ore
in the ground.
>>female in audience: Hum.
>>Steve Lehto: And so his men stopped, they
didn't know what to do, and Burt whips out
his solar compass and says, "Guys I got the
answer here. I got a solar compass." And the
amazing thing is that his men found iron ore
samples in the ground and said, "Here's the
problem. It's the iron ore samples." And so
they wrote a report describing the iron ore
deposits in the area and those reports later
became the foundation of the iron ore industry
up there.
And yet when Burt talks about it, all he talks
about is, "My solar compass works. I've been
vindicated." And so it's interesting because
the other guys are like, "Hey someone gonna
get rich." He's like, "No my solar compass
works."
[laughter]
So, so when it comes to Houghton's discoveries
Burt's often credited with being the one who
discovered the iron and that's fine, but Burt
was actually working for Houghton, so he gets
kind of like an assist on that.
So along with that, one of the most important
stories I-I kinda touched on was I mentioned
the Ontonagon Boulder. The Ontonagon Boulder
was out in the woods 'till about 1843. And
what happened was as the stories drifted south
about it an enterprising guy in Detroit named
Julius Eldred decided he's gonna go get it.
[laughter]
And so this was back wild, wild west days
almost. He gathers up some men and some equipment
and he heads up to the Ontonagon Boulder and
there's a whole story behind it because some
other guy sitting on claims it's his. It's
like a Dr. Seuss story.
And this guy manages to talk the other guy
out of it to pay him some money and he starts
using winches and blocks and tackle and all
kinds of heavy equipment and he manages to
pry the thing out of the ground and he gets
it loose. He then puts it on a train car and
he actually brought his own train tracks up
there and actually brought train tracks and
rolls it and he does this thing where he brings
the train tracks around. There's a Wallace
and Gromit cartoon that does the exact same
thing --
[laughter]
but much faster motion.
So he gets the iron the-the-the Ontonagon
Boulder down to the shore just as the army
shows up. And the U.S. Army had sent somebody
up there 'cause they'd heard the rumor that
someone's prying the Ontonagon Boulder lose
and the Army said, "Guess what? That's federal
property. You don't have a permit to pull
that out the ground. It's ours now."
[laughter]
And so the federal government seized the Ontonagon
Boulder from Julius Eldred and took it to
the War Department in Washington. Julius Eldred
followed it there and filed a lawsuit against
the government saying it was his. He wound
up paying a couple thousand dollars for it
and long story, it winds up at the Smithsonian
in the basement.
So if you go now to the Smithsonian you can
see the Ontonagon Boulder. Like I said it's
about this big. The amazing thing is it weighs
three thousand seven hundred pounds. Now thirty-seven
hundred pounds is a lot of weight. A lot of
cars on the road today are right around that,
thirty-seven hundred pounds.
But amazingly by today's standards that's
not even a significant boulder because they
have found much larger boulders than that.
So if you ever go to the Upper Peninsula and
you go to the town called Calumet, as you
drive into Calumet there's a park called Agassiz
Park and there's a statute of a guy named
Rudolph Agassiz sitting there and-and directly
in front of him is a big piece of copper and
it's about the size of this screen here but
upright on the side of the road, and that
weighs 9,000 pounds. So it weighs more than
double what the Ontonagon Boulder weighs and
that's just by the side of the road. Anybody
can go by it with a tow strap and just grab
it, okay? About three bucks a pound these
days so, get you some money.
[laughter]
The weird thing is that that's nowhere near
the largest boulder they found up there. They
actually found a larger boulder that's on
display if you, you went to Tech?
>>female in audience: Um-hum.
>>Steve Lehto: Up at the top of the hill the
other side of this, the canal the Quincy Mine
Hoist
>>female in audience: yeah.
>>Steve Lehto: Okay, the houses up there.
Inside that building they have on display
this huge boulder of copper they found at
the bottom of Lake Superior that weighs 33,000
pounds and it's about 20 or 30 feet of water.
Some scuba divers were out there and one of
them noticed that this looks like copper.
They came back and checked sure enough it's
all copper. And they got a barge and one of
these huge listing straps and they picked
this thing up off the bottom of the lake and
they put it on display, 33,000 pounds. That's
the third largest boulder we know about up
there.
About two or three years ago some construction
workers working near the top of the hill doing
a parking lot for Portage Health Systems scraping
down, hit a piece of copper that weighed 56,000
pounds. And that was such a big piece of copper
that it actually was in the way and the company's
called Moyle Construction and Moyle's a big
name up there. And the Moyle Construction
actually went to the property owners and said,
"We'll split the cost with you if you'll let
us remove this and sell it." And so they took
the 56,000 pound boulder out of there and
sold it. The rumor is they sold it to the
Chinese 'cause they're chewing up all kinds
of copper right now their infrastructure building,
[laughter]
dams and all that.
But they've actually found an even a larger
piece of copper. It's on private property
out there, the [ ], but that's just kinda
funny because the Ontonagon Boulder turned
out to be so small by-by comparison. But that's
the one that had all the imagination sparked
of all the prospectors and so on.
So anyway as Houghton's done with all his
exploring, he's done with all his surveying,
he's 36 years old. He's been offered a job
to teach at the University of Michigan, which
he's accepted by the way.
But you have to remember that U of M back
then is different than the U of M today. When
U of M started in Ann Arbor, it was actually
originally in Detroit and they moved it. If
you're ever in the City-County Building, which
is the building in Detroit that's got the
Spirit of Detroit out in front of it, there's
a plaque inside the building on the wall and
it says, "This is the site of the original
University of Michigan."
They moved it to Ann Arbor. It had a class
out here, the entire student body was 12 students.
So I like to explain to people that you could
probably have fielded a basketball team, if
they'd invented the game yet --
[laughter]
but you couldn't fill the full football team,
unless you wanna play both ways which I suppose
you could.
And then the student body dropped below that
before it recovered and eventually became
what it is today.
But Houghton had agreed to work out here and
he's going to be on the faculty. He was technically
on the faculty before that but it's unclear
if he ever actually traveled out here to teach
or he may have come out here and guest lectured
or something but.
He was also the Mayor of Detroit one term,
president of the first Detroit Public School
Board. He did all the exploring we talked
of the reports we talked about.
And in 1845 as he's wrapping up his expedition
he was in Eagle River in October, which is
kind of late in the year up there. And he
had some men who were down on the beach who
were still surveying and they were wrapping
up their work for the, for the season.
So he went down by boat to visit them and
to drop off some supplies and also to pick
up two men who needed to get back into a boat,
a ship to get back to Sault Saint Marie.
And on his trip back they got hit by a snow
storm in October. Now if you're ever at the
Upper Peninsula you know it can snow up there
in August. I've been up there in August and
it snowed. So they get hit by a snow storm
in October and the boat capsizes and Houghton
and two of the men in the boat with him drowned.
The two voyagers with Houghton actually make
it to shore as his dog makes it to shore as
well, it's important to the story.
And the voyagers go into town and say, "Hey
look Douglass Houghton's boat just capsized."
They come out, they search, they don't find
him. They find one of the guys the next morning
and they actually find one of, they find Houghton
himself, they find his body the following
spring.
And when the news reached Detroit that Douglass
Houghton had drowned it was a-a big deal as,
it had the equivalent of like a state funeral
in Detroit. All the mayors were there, the
Governor was there.
He's buried in the Elmwood Cemetery in Detroit.
So if you ever get a chance to go to Detroit
and visit the cemetery Elmwood a lot of important,
famous people in Michigan history are buried
there including Douglass Houghton.
There is memorials to Houghton around. There's
actually a memorial to Houghton here on the
campus over by the graduate, the-the Hatcher
Graduate Library and it's a, it's, they call
it a cenotaph. It's a [pillar] that's chopped
off at the top indicating a life cut short
and they call it the Professors Monument because
it's Houghton and three other professors who
all died young right around the same time:
Houghton, Fox, Denton and Whiting. And it's
kind of tucked up against the building most
people don't know it's there.
There's also a memorial to Houghton at Eagle
River not far from where he drowned and then
as you mentioned there's waterfalls that are
named after him called the Douglass Houghton
Falls. Did you ever seem them when you were
up there?
>>female in audience: I don't think so.
>>Steve Lehto: The Douglass Houghton Falls
are on private property now. But they're the
tallest waterfalls in Michigan.
>>female in audience: Um.
>>Steve Lehto: And it's very sad because there
is a, you'd never imagine that they're there
about two or three miles southwest of Calumet,
kind of out in the woods --
>>female in audience: Yeah.
>>Steve Lehto: and there, you're walking on
[Elson's] Dropoff and it's like a hundred,
I don't know if it's a hundred feet down.
Drunken Michigan Tech students liked going
over there --
[laughter]
and scaling up and down the side of that wall.
As you can imagine that's what else can you
do up there for entertainment?
[laughter]
And it got to the point where the sheriff
was going up, taking people off the side of
this cliff every so often, and the owner of
the property realized that one of these days
someone's gonna fall and sue him saying, "You
shouldn't have let me climb your waterfall."
So he actually had to put a fence up across
the thing so you can't go there now. And the
weird thing about is that number one, the
falls are misspelled it's always Douglass
dash Houghton and his name's not hyphenated.
I don't know why they do that.
[laughter]
Number two, there's no evidence that he ever
saw the waterfalls because he doesn't mention
them in any of his writings. And in fact he
never actually made it to that part of the
peninsula because that was right dead center
and he went around the edges for the most
part. So he probably didn't even see it. But
it's interesting 'cause it's named after him.
[laughter]
I-I often get asked about Houghton Lake 'cause
there's a Houghton Lake and people go, did,
and it was named after him but again he didn't
discover that lake.
But if you look at it, it's Houghton, Higgins,
Burt, and Mullett are the four lakes right
across the knuckles. All four of them are
surveyors. So Burt I already told you about,
and Mullett and Higgins were two other surveyors.
So it's a good trivia question if you wanna
know why those lakes were named that way.
[laughter]
It's interesting I spoke at a library at Houghton
Lake not too long ago and someone asked me
about that and I had to explain to them that
the bad news is that Higgins was actually
a very bad surveyor.
[laughter]
And we know this because in books on the history
of surveying in Michigan, Sylvester Higgins
when you got a job to contract to survey property
who's to say you're doing it right? I go out
in the woods and I come back and say, "Yep,
it's surveyed. Here you go, here's your papers,"
and you pay me and I leave. So to make sure
you would do a good job you had to post a
bond to guarantee that you did it.
And in fact for Houghton to get the job in
the Upper Peninsula he's probably one of the
few people who could get that job because
the bond was so exorbitant that very few people
could have gotten that much of a bond back
then.
Sylvester Higgins posted a bond, did a bunch
of really bad survey work, got sued by everybody,
it ate up the bond, and they, it got to the
point where they were going to come after
him personally and he fled the state. And
he spent his later years surveying in California.
[laughter]
So, but-but he got a lake named after him
so that-that's good.
[laughter]
So but unfortunately Houghton died in 1845
like I said. It's interesting because he died
so young. He had been elected a Mayor of Detroit.
There's no question though that he probably
would have gotten elected Governor or some
other type of high political office. It's
interesting because so many people know-know
his name, because his name's on stuff, but
most people don't know what he did.
So it's the exploration of Michigan, it's
reports that pop, that he got the word out
popularly as to where the copper was and what
it takes to get it out of the ground, and
then he also would have had to have know more
about Michigan than anybody else, than anybody
else during his lifetime.
And it's interesting you go back and look
at the history of America, as-as-as the civilization
headed West. You know you've got the explorers
and right behind them you've got the surveyors.
And Houghton was both and so at one point
in time though he was probably the guy who
knew the most about the State of Michigan.
So that's the story of Douglass Houghton and
I got answers if you've got questions.
>>female in audience: What happened with his
dog?
[laughter]
>>Steve Lehto: His dog?
I'm glad you asked me that.
[laughter]
His dog is named Meem and you wouldn't know
from the cover here but you'd know if you
look in the inside photograph here that his
dog is at his feet in this painting by Alvah
Bradish.
And Alvah Bradish was Douglass Houghton's
brother-in-law.
>>female in audience: Um-hum.
>>Steve Lehto: And Alvah wrote a very, very
nice biography of Douglass Houghton in the
1880's which is not probably not terribly
historically accurate. It's filled with all
kinds of glowing praise and the guy walked
on water. And one of the things that he does
mention though is that Meem made it back to
Detroit and was shipped back East and spent
his last years of his life on Douglass Houghton's
parents' farm.
>>female voice in audience: Oh my gosh.
[laughter]
So if it's true, it's a great story. I don't
know if it's true. I was discussing that with
somebody recently and they said, "Well what
are the logistics of shipping a dog back in
the 1840's?"
[laughter]
And I'm not sure.
I do like to point out though that Alvah Bradish
was a painter and he's not a bad painter I
mean he did, he did the portrait on the cover.
But he wasn't a terribly great painter either.
He spent a lot of his time trying to talk
people into letting him paint their portraits.
[laughter]
And when I was doing research on this I encountered
correspondence between Bradish and other people
and there all these rejection letters saying,
"Dear Mr. Bradish. Thank you very much for
your, for the offer to paint my wife's portrait
or my portrait but at this point in time we
don't need our portrait painted." This, over
and over and over again, rejection after rejection.
And the one time that Douglass Houghton sat
for a portrait, Bradish painted in about 1835,
he's seated in a chair as typical portrait
guy sitting in a chair painting. And that
painting still exists, it's at the Geological
Survey at Lansing.
After Douglass Houghton died, Alvah Bradish
then painted this life size portrait, full
size portrait of him standing in front of
what he imagined the pictured rocks looked
like. Alvah Bradish never saw the picture
of rocks. That's obvious by the painting.
[laughter]
But it's funny because in a time before photographs
how would you know what they look like? And
so you'd have drawings of the pictured rocks
or else you've have your word descriptions
of the pictured rocks that were in the newspapers
and so on.
But it's kind of funny 'cause I-I-I first
when I saw the portrait I'm like, "Well, it's-it's
a great portrait of Houghton but it's not
a very good portrait of the pictured rocks."
But that full-sized portrait hangs at the
Capital Building in Lansing. And that's interesting
too because there's a twin of that portrait
at the Michigan Tech Mineral Museum. And there's
also two or three duplicates of the Houghton
portrait. There's one at the Detroit Historical
Museum, one at the Portage District Library,
and it looks like Alvah Bradish when he couldn't
get other people to agree to let him paint
their portrait he would then just start knocking
Houghton portraits
[laughter]
'cause he knew that he had a market for 'em.
So
>>female in audience: I'm always amazed by
the preservation of the historical knowledge.
How, talk about how the research was for this
book or how challenging is it to put all of
these pieces back together again?
>>Steve Lehto: Well this-this, see it's interesting
because for this book everybody in the book
has passed away. So I've got to go out and
find stuff they left behind. I've written
books where everything, every person I'm talking
about is still alive and I can track them
down and interview them and that's very, very
easy.
Luckily, though a lot of the people in this
book kept journals. So Douglass Houghton's
field notebooks still exist and they're at
the Clarke Historical Library in Mt. Pleasant.
A lot of his papers though wound up at the
Bentley Historical Library here in Ann Arbor.
And so I had to go to these different libraries
and dig through reams and reams of papers.
But like for instance to see, I have a photograph
here in the book of one right inside, that's
Douglass, one of Douglass Houghton's field
notebooks.
>>female in audience: Hum.
>>Steve Lehto: And he had about 20 of these
that survived and it's just a leather bound
book. It's like a size like a reporter's notebook.
It's got pencil marks where he's-he's written
in pencil and, "March 3rd 1841 here's what
I saw today" and just lists what he saw.
And it's fascinating because a lot of it has
got water spots on it; it got splashed by
the paddle of the canoe or something. And
he wasn't writing it thinking someone else
is gonna come by later and deconstruct it.
These are notes that he was keeping for himself.
Some of the other stuff, the journals the
other guys were writing I'm sure a lot of
them were expecting to get read, but they-they
seem to be very honest.
But that was a lot of fun, I mean some of
it's very mundane. I mean Douglass Houghton
four days in a row would say he saw rocks
and dirt
[laughter]
it wasn't, it wasn't real exciting stuff,
but it was, it was accurate. And so that was
a lot of fun. But that's-that's-that was the
neat part.
One of the most interesting things I found
doing this research was that Douglass Houghton
had a brother named Jacob. And Jacob was Douglass'
younger brother. And when Douglass Houghton
was exploring up on the Upper Peninsula, Jacob
Houghton got hired by a local mine, mining
group to-to help them scout for mine opportunities.
So the night that Houghton's boat capsized
Jacob Houghton was camping inland about two
miles. And someone in town actually ran into
the woods and found Jacob Houghton and said,
"Your brother's in a boat that just capsized."
Jacob Houghton came out and helped with the
search for his brother and I'd never heard
that before until I was going through the
papers at the Burton Historic Library in Detroit
and I was going through I think it's the Houghton
Family Papers they had, they had some-some
correspondence there. And they have the letter
that Jacob wrote to his parents explaining
what happened that night.
And previously the other historians who have
talked about Douglass Houghton had always
relied upon this report that was put together
by one of the guys who came down from Ft.
Wilkins at Copper Harbor to help with the
search, it was an Army guy.
And the Army guy came down a few days later,
he helped with the search, he interviewed
some people, he had to draft affidavits, and
he wrote a report and handed the report in.
And the report's fairly accurate but it lacks
the emotion of Jacob Houghton telling his
parents, "Here's how your son died." And he
explains the efforts they went to and what
he did to help them look and at one point
he got to the end of the beach and he climbed
a tree so he could look further down the beach;
little details like that that you don't get
anywhere else.
And I-I had the original letter in my hands,
it's in this beautiful, this scroll, the old
fountain pen. I mean it's amazing. So that's
a lot of the fun of doing this kind of research.
>>female in audience: That's great.
>>Steve Lehto: Yeah.
[pause]
>>female in audience: You talked a little
bit about before we were taping, but can you
talk a little bit about your next project
and what you're excited about with that? [laughs]
>>Steve Lehto: I am writing a book about,
I've written a book about the Chrysler Turbine
Car Project which was in 1963 Chrysler built
a fleet of jet powered cars. And it's interesting
they'd been working on jets since 1950. They
put a jet engine in a car in 1953 and they
finally decided that they had one that was
so practical that anybody could drive it.
So they built a fleet of 50 cars and loaned
them out to the public as like a big publicity
stunt. And so you could actually send a postcard
to Chrysler and if they drew your name and
decided that, you'd-you'd get a car for three
months that was jet powered.
And so housewives and accountants and just
average Joe Americans were getting these jet
cars and they all looked identical, they were
all painted this-this turbine bronze color.
They were very, they were a specific built
car so it's very unusual looking and they
sounded really funky. And so for two years
these cars were all over the place. They had
them on display at the World's Fair.
I mean I-I-I was very young but I remember
seeing 'em in traffic. You couldn't miss 'em
'cause of the sound they made. At the end
of the program, Chrysler rounded them all
up and destroyed 'em all. And they saved a
couple, but they destroyed most of them. And
it's one of those stories that ever since
I was a little kid it's always bugged me what
happened to those cars and why.
[laughter]
And it's one of those things that I sort,
I've always been thinking and thinking and
thinking about it and I ran into somebody
who knew some of the people working in the
program and started interviewing these people
and I realized this is actually a really,
really interesting story there.
So I wrote this whole story, finished the
manuscript, and couldn't get a publisher.
And so I actually put it aside and I wrote
a couple other books. This book and my Death's
Door book.
And then this-this is kind of strange, but
my Death's Door book is called Death's Door:
Truth Behind Michigan's Largest Mass Murder.
A bookstore in the Upper Peninsula of Michigan
ran an ad for that at Christmas and said,
"Makes a great Christmas gift," with a picture
of the cover of my book
[laughter]
and the cover of the book is dark and it's
got this shadow of a, of a, of a tombstone
on it
[laughter]
Somebody sent that ad into Jay Leno and he
ran that on his funny headlines segment
>>female in audience: Yeah.
>>Steve Lehto: So I'm sitting at home on a
Tuesday morning and
[laughter]
my phone starts ringing and people are going,
"Steve, you were on Jay Leno last night."
I'm like, "No, I was, I was
[laughter]
asleep last night."
So anyway I-I figured out what happened. So
I took a copy of Death's Door, I gift wrapped
it and I sent it to Jay Leno as a joke and
said, "Here, Merry Christmas."
[laughter]
But then on a whim I took the Turbine Car
manuscript and stuck it in there and said,
"I know you're a car guy, check this out."
And I stuck my business card in there and
like two weeks later he called me. And he
said, "Steven, this is great." He goes, "Why
don't you get it published?" And I said, "Because
it's a car book and for some odd reason people
pigeonhole car books as being, 'well it's
a car book.'" Go into Borders and the car
books are in the corner. Barnes and Noble
they're in the corner.
And he's like, "Well, I'm gonna hang on to
your card, okay?" And I said, "Sure, hang
on to my card, I don't care."
[laughter]
Well he did those three shows in Michigan
last summer and after the shows were over,
he's at the Palace of Auburn Hills, Chrysler's
right there. He's got friends at Chrysler.
He goes over to Chrysler and there's a big
test track and he's driving and they'll let
him drive cars from the museum and they let
him drive a turbine car. And he asked them,
"Could I buy one of your turbine cars?" And
apparently he got them to sell him one because
>>male in audience: Uh-huh.
>>Steve Lehto: I'm at my office a week later
and my phone rings. It's Jay Leno again.
[laughter]
And he starts asking me very specific questions
about the turbine car and I finally go, "Why
do you need to know this suddenly?" He goes,
"I can't tell ya." I said, "Well
[laughter]
there's nine of 'em in the world, you're asking
me questions about how to keep one running
so I am assuming you got one of the one's
that runs.
[laughter]
You were in Michigan two weeks ago at Chrysler
any chance you bought one from Chrysler?"
He said, "You can't tell anybody, you can't
tell anybody."
[laughter]
Well I can tell people now.
But anyways I got him a bunch of information
about the car. The guy's who's the head mechanic
on the program is a friend of mine. I have
a technical service manual that would have
come out if the car had been put in production
which he didn't have. So I got him all this
information and so as he called me to thank
me he said, "If you're ever in California
I'll let you drive the car."
[laughter]
So I flew out to California as fast as I could
get there
[laughter]
and he let me drive the car. And so he gives
me a tour of his garage. He calls it his garage,
it's got 105 cars in it
[laughter]
he's got 95 motorcycles, he's got all this
crazy stuff. He's got, he's gotta staff of
like 12 guys who do nothing but help him keep
his cars running.
>>female in audience: Geez.
>>male in audience: Um.
>>Steve Lehto: And we're talking and he said,
he goes, "I don't understand why you can't
the book published." I said, "Because it's
a car book." And he goes, "Well if it'll help
you, I'll write a forward for you."
So when I got back to Michigan I started pitching
the idea at agents going, "I have the book
written and Jay Leno will write a forward
for me." And I got an agent who said he could
sell that and he did.
So Chicago Review Press is publishing the
book this October. The book is in gathering
stages right now. We have a very nice endorsement
from P.J. O'Rourke
[laughter]
and that will be out in October.
>>female in audience: Very exciting.
>>female in audience: Wonderful.
>>Steve Lehto: Yeah.
>>female in audience: Great story.
[laughter]
>>Steve Lehto: That's story's better than
the book.
>>female in audience: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>commentator: Well thank you so much for
coming. We really enjoyed
>>Steve Lehto: Thank you.
>>commentator: having you.
>>Steve Lehto: I wish I could have done the
slides for you.
>>commentator: I know. We'll have to
>>female in audience: Sorry. It was a pleasure
to have you.
>>Steve Lehto: That's okay.
>>commentator: It was a honor that you came
to see us.
>>Steve Lehto: Well, thank you.
>>commentator: We really appreciate it.
>>Steve Lehto: Thank you.
>>commentator: Thank you. Alright.
[applause]